[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec pascal affi n'guessan
l'ancien premier ministre de la côte
d'ivoire candidat pour la présidentielle
du s p é
le front populaire ivoirien l'ancien
parti le parti de laurent gbagbo l'ex
chef de l'état ivoirien pascal affi
n'guessan merci bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation d'ayrté france et
je vous le mets aussi des occasions mais
aux frais du mr mais du votre chien
alors que pensez-vous du troisième
mandat d'alassane ouattara l'actuel
président de la côte d'ivoire nous nous
la condamnons et nous lui demandons de
revenus c'est cette décision parce que
d'abord elle est anticonstitutionnelle
la position ivoirienne prévoit deux
mandats mais se heurtera vient de
terminer ses deux mandats il n'est pas
droit à un troisième ensuite lui même a
affirmé à la face du monde et il
circulait de la course qui n'était pas
candidat à une élection présidentielle
en 2020 et nous ne comprenons pas et
nous n'acceptons pas et qu'ils puissent
commettre c'est de se parjurer un don
pour des raisons éthiques des raisons
juridiques
nous demandons à monsieur ouattara de se
retirer de la course et j'ai dû lui
aussi pour des raisons de sécurité
nationale
parce que ça colle et 21 pose
manifestement des brûlures graves de
cohésion sociale l'instabilité politique
et pour ces raisons monsieur ouattara
devrait se retirer pour éviter à la côte
d'ivoire est notre crise il ya déjà des
manifestations de la contestation est ce
que le front populaire ivoirien votre
parti va se joindre justement à cette
contestation ou
vous allez justement appelé à la retenue
les manifestations sont un mode
démocratique d'expression lorsqu'elles
sont pacifiques
c'était le droit constitutionnel et ses
manifestations révèle la colère
populaire et je la comprends je la
partage et et c'est pour ces raisons de
l'arrêt pour éviter le désordre et
l'instabilité que nous invitons
instamment de se voir à renoncer à ce
troisième mandat
ceci dit c'est dans les urnes et que la
décision doit être fait et je souhaite
que ce soit donc dans les yeux que nous
mettions fin à cette crise binotto pays
depuis 30 ans vous êtes en lice pour la
prochaine présidentielle alassane
ouattara l'actuel président également un
cacique de du champ politique ivoirien
henri konan-bédié pour le pdc y en lice
il en manque un je pense que vous voyez
de qui je veux parler
il a demandé son passeport pour revenir
en côte d'ivoire s'il revient et s'il
décide d'être candidat laurent gbagbo
que ferez vous mais je l'aide il a
affirmé à plusieurs reprises 9 2
appartenant à la même famille politique
le bilan bagouet le fondateur du parti
il a exercé le bois d'état comme un 10
ans il dispose d'une réputation d'une
autorité incontestable
en côte d'ivoire comme en afrique
et donc si les candidats évidemment ça
veut dire que je ne suis pas candidat et
qu'il serait dommageable pour notre
famille politique il est venu candidat
en lice pour la même élection
présidentielle aussi le président
laurent gbagbo est candidat et je ne
suis pas candidat au contraire je suis
dans l'équipe de campagne pour nom
serait à votre candidature vous parlez
de la réunification du f pays vous dites
que cette réunification est en cours
il ya un aspect y ait ou 2f pays
vous et vos militants et puis les autres
les pro gbagbo
non il ya un seul fbi même si à
l'intérieur il ya des débats lydia des
polémiques ce qu'ils appellent même une
dissidence mais n'empêche qu'il y avait
sept pays puisque tout cela se réclament
du rpi personnes les 6 g de notre parti
politique
personne n'a quitté le parti et le pays
est représentée au niveau national comme
international par une seule entité par
une seule direction donc il n'ya pas du
rpi et nous travaillons à faire en sorte
que tous ces militants l'a dit on se
rassemble autour des intérêts du front
populaire ivoirien et les intérêts de la
bolivie
vous avez été candidat en 2015 est
arrivé 2e largement battu par alassane
ouattara
cette fois il vous faudra si laurent
gbagbo ne revient pas s'il n'est pas
candidat il vous faudra une large base
pour pouvoir vous imposer
est-ce que vous pourrez compter
réellement sur les pro gbagbo les gorges
qui disent gbagbo ou rien logiquement
devrait pouvoir compter sur eux parce
que comme il est déjà indiqué ce qui
nous réunit est largement plus
importante de ce type nous diviser ce
qui nous unit c'est d'abord l'intérêt de
notre pays et notre pays aujourd'hui a
intérêt à opérer le changement pour la
renaissance a intérêt à porter à la tête
de l'état le front populaire ivoirien et
les valeurs est il anime les valeurs de
solidarité de christie's gré social ces
malheurs sont fondamentales les valeurs
d'unité nationale
ces valeurs sont fondamentales
aujourd'hui pour la côte d'ivoire est
d'accord étant donné que nous sommes
dans l'action politique justement au
service de notre pays parce que nous
souffrons de la division de la pauvreté
qui sévissent dans notre pays je sus que
nous serons nous élever au dessus de
l'eau frustration au dessus de l'eau
division qui ne sont que secondaires
d'une contradiction qui ne sont que
secondaires
d'abord nous attaquer à la contradiction
principale qui est largement politique
qui est de porter au pouvoir
une
famille politique socialiste qui a animé
deux valeurs humaines fondamentales
essaye tout cas que cela qui devrait
logiquement amener nos camarades a pu
vérifier le rassemblement autour du
candidat du front populaire ivoirien
quitte à ce que par la suite nous
puissions trouver des solutions à ceux
qui minimisent acdi aux locaux situés au
départ secondaire à l'intérieur du
bateau donc je consulte sur deux sens de
la responsabilité et suis persuadé que
nos camarades seront à la hauteur de la
pinte des plages et les guarin mais vous
savez aussi que pour de nombreux
militants du fpi fidèles à laurent
gbagbo vous êtes celui affi n'guessan
qui a trahi et laurent gbagbo ont parlé
de la présidentielle de 2015
comment vous gérez cette étiquette qui
vous colle à la peau non mais je crois
qu'ils l'ont bien compris
à partir du moment où eux mêmes
aujourd'hui et comprennent qu'il faut
rester dans le jeu politique c'est de me
reprocher hier qu'il faut participer aux
élections ce qui m'est reproché hier
qu'il faut privilégier le dialogue
politique ce qui peut me reprocher et il
est intègre et una cette forme de
trahison a pas d'éléments qui nous ont
compris que qu'il faut sortir de la
logique de la paix différence pour
trouver des solution apaisée au problème
n'a pas de loi je crois que j'ai
vraiment compris qu'il se sent prendre
cette auto que c'est des positions
stratégiques et tactiques à adopter
n'était nullement un acte de trahison
mais une posture pour transformer comme
il est indiqué et ce sentiment de
frustration d'un v6 que nous avons vécu
en 2009 en énergie à stratégie pour la
reconquête du pouvoir donc abandonné une
posture pris une posture et sentiment de
rancoeur pour ses poètes le pro actif au
s'engager en faveur de la reconquête du
pouvoir n'est pas humain et n'a que
triaud vous l'avez rencontrée à laurent
gbagbo instant en début d'année vous lui
avez certainement parler de votre
candidature comment est-ce qu'il a
accueilli cette candidature mais le bobo
inscrit tout ce que nous devons faire
d'abord à la dynamique de l'unité du
parti et c'est donc autour de cette
unité est que nous travaillons
il sait aussi que nos chants populaires
et un doigt revenu au pouvoir qu'il a
l'obligation de participer au jeu
politique aux élections pour retrouver
le poids d'état soit avec lui qu'il est
présent et candidat soit avec un autre
candidat du parti est longue je suis
persuadé que étant donné qu'il est
favorable à l'unité il ne peut qu'être
favorable à matanda du nantes où les
tailles de l'air former et de la tenue
du congrès qui m'a porté à la tête de ma
portée comme candidat du parti et je
jouais reste en contact avec lui pour
que ce soit ensemble que nous allions la
reconquête du pouvoir s'il davanture il
n'est pas là parce que c'est avec un
derby au pouvoir que lui gbagbo pour la
rue édith une fin en côte d'ivoire et de
recevoir des leçons
alors puisque vous êtes en contact avec
laurent gbagbo vous a peut-être mis dans
la confidence
quelles sont ses intentions est ce que
lui il a réellement envie de revenir en
côte d'ivoire pour se présenter
être candidat à cette présidentielle oh
je peux me référer à ce que son avocat
madame habiba touré a déclaré
dernièrement lorsque la question lui a
été posée sur les chaînes de télé et
française que ce qui prouve qu pas que
le clan gbagbo s'est d'abord retrouvé
l'entièreté de la rdc mouvement des
serres et doit d'aller devenir est
rentré en côte d'ivoire et une fois
qu'il est en côte d'ivoire le tout le
reste est est possible et envisageable
mais il faut d'abord que nous régulions
la question de la libération totale de
l'apurement du dossier de la cour pénale
internationale
tu crois que c'est ce qui est d'abord
fondamentale à partir de là tout et tout
est ouvert
maintenant que ce problème n'est pas
réglé il est illusoire d'envisager
d'échafauder des plans du caviar à bout
de toute façon son courant d'ici cette
présidentielle en côte d'ivoire qui va
se dérouler le 31 octobre
vos relations avec un charles blé goudé
quel rôle vous lui prêtez depuis l'est
ou
il réside en vue justement de cette
élection
mais je pense qu'il est important à
jouer étant donné qu'il incarne
aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire
la jeunesse africaine la jeunesse qui se
bat pour la dignité africaine pour la
souveraineté africaine pour le progrès
de l'afrique à partir du moment où il a
appelé un autre but pour cet engagement
il est des symboles il est une référence
et que je suis persuadé que les
positions qu'il prendra à l'occasion des
fêtes élections auront un impact
indéniable sur l'issue du scrutin
pascal affi n'guessan on va marquer une
pause et on va se retrouver dans un
instant restez avec nous sur rtl
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec pascal affi n'guessan
candidat du front populaire ivoirien
pour la présidentielle le f pays
pascal affi n'guessan ce plus de 7
millions d'électeurs inscrits neuf cent
mille électeurs supplémentaires sur une
population à peu près de 25 millions
d'habitants est ce que ça signifie que
la révision des listes électorales a
porté ses fruits dans votre pays pas
totalement basse que si cette prévision
avait été inclusive et transparente
nous aurions pu facilement passer à au
moins 9 millions voix 10 millions
d'électeurs et ce qui est conforme à la
démographie ivoiriennes ont
malheureusement le processus n'a pas été
conduit dans la transparence et la été
précipitée à telle enseigne qu à l'heure
actuelle beaucoup les demandeurs du sud
majeures n'ont pas pu se ferait avec jc
alors qu'ils ont alors posté sur les
documents nécessaires et donc c'est une
opération qui a connu un meilleur sort
que celui est ce que c'est le dernier le
sait 2018 mais qui n'a pas été à la
hauteur de ce que nous prévoyons dans le
contexte de la pandémie le débat
constitutionnel qui s'annonce ardue au
tour du troisième mandat d'alassane
ouattara il faut maintenir le scrutin au
31 octobre
oui moi je pense que le plus tôt serait
le mieux
lorsqu'on regarde la situation dans
laquelle se trouve notre pays il faut
aller rapidement à une élection pour
doter le pays d'une légitimité moore
savez bien que il n'ya pas longtemps le
pays a malheureusement perdu 100 ans
premier ministre
les penyes amadou gon coulibaly paix à
son âme
le vivent les a démissionné des
ministres importants entité le rhdp
appelle ans c'est que à un moment donné
le chef de tête est la seule autorité et
que le pays était dans une véritable
crise institutionnelle -la la défiance à
l'égard du pouvoir et des menus massive
pratiquement plus disent qu'aujourd'hui
le pays est dans l'insécurité
exceptionnel et juridique
il faut donc une nouvelle légitimité et
qu'on dirait indiqué le plus tôt serait
le mieux
vous souhaitez que la communauté
internationale s'implique pour garantir
des élections transparentes
elle a déjà impliqué à travers le plus
des drogues organisations
internationales à travers certains pays
amis
nous souhaitons que cette implication
soit permanente parce que la question de
la démocratie at il péché et du sml
n'est pas seulement l'apanage de la côte
d'ivoire la côte d'ivoire est impliqué
dans un certain nombre d'accords
internationaux sur la transparence
électorale sur des droits de l'homme sur
la bonne gouvernance sur toutes ces
questions
la communauté internationale a le droit
de riga si ce qui se passe en côte
d'ivoire parce que ce qui se passe en
côte d'ivoire intéresse l'ensemble de la
planète la somme des états membres de
l'organisation des nations unies on va
peut-être évoqué les alliances possibles
pour le fbi
le pdc il le parti d'henri konan bédié
l'ancien chef de l'état en côte d'ivoire
tant la main ou aux pro gbagbo mais vous
vous semblez réfractaires à cette main
tendue pour quelles raisons les pro
gbagbo comme vous le dites
santini dissidence du front populaire
ivoirien ils sont dans l'illégalité
mais le synode de laurent qu'ils usent
des apu et du front populaire ivoirien
et des c'est un emblème du parti parce
que nous ne souhaitons pas que cette
querelle interne dégénère en
affrontement en plus profondes
mais n'empêche que niçois l'illégalité
ils sont hors la loi et nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre qu'un parti qui
ambitionne gouverner un pays s'appuie
sur du légalité parce que tout
simplement cela va lui permettre
d'atteindre son objectif politique
donc c'est comme une comtesse penser que
le camarade choisissent
l'unité dont l'alliance pour détriment
de l'unité et deux fois ce que nous
connaissons dans tous les cas de figure
où tous les partis politiques à un
portable au deuxième tour n'est pas le
cas des parties allumé au deuxième tour
aura besoin de celui qui aura été
éliminés dont nous sommes
incontournables
le pci incontournable le rhdp
incontournable non correspond ni ouvert
pour conclure une alliance électorale au
deuxième tour avec le pdci si nous nous
sommes nous en face au rhdp et de
supercherie que si le connaissez y est
éliminé de la course et il n'aura pas
d'autre choix que d'accepter cette
alliance ne serait ce que pour préserver
le minimum il en est de même ainsi nous
concerne enfin que le pdci a soutenu au
sein du rhdp
cette alliance houphouétiste alassane
ouattara c'était en 2010 déjà
il ya eu beaucoup de divisions au sein
du rhdp vous craignez vous justement
quand vous à lyon avec le pdc y est bien
il y encore des le pdci rosso ton contre
vous au final bien vous savez une
alliance s est une alliance cela dit
qu'elle est peu elle a toujours une
durée de vie elle correspond à la
réalité et géopolitiques du moment est
donc aujourd'hui la configuration du
paysage politique est tel que nous
sommes tous condamnés les serait ce que
pour construire une majorité de tendre
la main et aux autres parties de trouver
un compromis programmatique sur ce que
nous devons proposer à nos compatriotes
mais ceci dit et nous ne sommes pas dans
cette alliance de façon éternelle mais
nous devons nous appuyer s'était pas
construire une majorité total humanité
durable qui est soit porté par les
valeurs de gauche qui passe à portée par
des valeurs socialistes
donc étant donné le contexte nous
pouvons trouver un compromis un
programme minimum de gouvernement avec
un parti politique qui partage avec nous
un minimum de valeurs c'est la
démocratie l'unité nationale
sur le progrès économique et social
notre pays mais notre objectif
stratégique c'est comment faire pour que
la gauche soit pleinement au pouvoir
pour appliquer totalement est pleinement
un programme de vous reprocher
finalement alassane ouattara war hdp de
ne pas renouveler la classe politique
c'est aussi le cas dans votre partie
vous étiez présent au plus fort au tout
début de cette crise ivoirienne qui
remonte au début des années 2000 henri
konon bédié est aussi un cacique jeu les
dits du champ politique ivoirien
finalement il ya eu cette problématique
de du renouvellement de la classe
politique ivoirienne elle vous concerne
aussi oui mais avec des vrais moindre
aide les grilles moyenne parce que
monsieur ali konan bédié à 86 ans non
comme pratiquement prêt près de vingt
ans de différence entre nous donc on
peut pas nommer rumeurs qui l'égalité
il en est de même des autres leaders
politiques majeures je peux dire que
fatima
je ne suis pas aussi jeune que ça mais
par rapport à ses 10 ans qui ayant
exercé réticents actuellement dans la
peau ce qui apparaît comme un cadet est
évidemment personnel malgré pas envie de
m'éterniser à la tête du front populaire
ivoirien ou même comme candidat du front
populaire ivoirien
mais nous considérons une génération de
transition entre la rénovation haricot
blanc dédié et la génération en blé
goudé charles et autres et donc un nom
devant créer les conditions pour que
cette nouvelle génération qui frappent à
la porte tous vers un pays stabilisé
tout une démocratie solide de manière à
ce que avec cette génération qui est à
venir
le pays véritablement rejoignent quand
des pays démocratiques où les élections
le sens parce qu'il ait pas de crise
post électorale mais pas une transition
pacifique de témoins dont il devra et
l'autre la nomination
du ministre de la défense ahmed bakayoko
a à la primature vous pensez que c'est
un gage de sécurité pour le pays on sait
qu'il a joué un rôle durant la crise
post électorale
et c'est vrai que la fièvre monte dans
votre pays on craint effectivement il ya
toujours ce spectre d'une crise post
électorale
on s'en souvient en 2010 qui a fait on
le rappelle 3000 morts oui prélasser sur
la sécurité n'est pas la question d'un
député ou d'une personnalité c'est une
question d'une question politique des
stratégies politiques de programme
politique
et si nous ne faisons pas en sorte que
la démocratie s'installe durablement
cody watts qui ne luttons pas contre les
discriminations contre les exclusions
quand les frustrations tu nous ne nous
battons pas pour unifier liste
indépendante transparente
nous ne créerons pas les conditionneurs
de la sécurité quelle que soit la
personne qui sera à la tête des forces
armées ou à la tête de l'état alors ma
question de la sécurité est une question
globale d'une question
multidimensionnelle et notre programme
que nous proposons justement à nos
compatriotes c'est de faire en sorte que
à travers la réforme de l'état
atteindrait la réforme de l'économie la
création d'emplois pour les jeunes
la lutte contre les discrimination à
l'endroit des femmes des personnes
handicapées et après leur positionnement
international de la cua dû voir pour
améliorer ses relations avec ses pays
voisins avec l'ensemble des pays de la
planète
nous créerons les conditions d'une paix
durable la stabilité dans notre pays
merci beaucoup
pascal affi n'guessan pour cette grande
interview accordée à rtl france une
grande interview que vous pouvez
retrouver en podcast sur notre site et
nos réseaux sociaux notre site arte
france point tv merci de votre attention
à très bientôt
[Musique]